hi guys I have another question for you
does ketosis cause hypothyroidism I hear
that a lot
no it doesn't it's not the low
carbohydrates that cause a slow thyroid
it is a low calorie diet that will do
that why because when you start cutting
calories you put a lot of stress on the
endocrine system especially because
you're not getting enough nutrients yes
you're running your body on fat possibly
but you're depriving yourself of
nutrients and the thing about a weak
endocrine gland is it's very sensitive
to nutritional deficiencies it's still
not healed it's not robust enough so
you're not constantly consuming
especially the minerals and because the
thyroid gland is it's a situation where
you have very slow metabolism that means
the uptake of nutrients is low already
because you don't have the intracellular
enzymes to start to metabolize so
basically when you go in a ketosis diet
your hunger goes way way down and some
people just don't eat very frequently
and the problem is they don't get the
nutrition so if you're going to do this
and you have a hypothyroid state just to
prevent it start taking more minerals
start taking sea kelp iodine selenium
certain nutritional things and make sure
you're eating enough just the right
things okay so it's nothing about the
low-calorie diet that will destroy the
thyroid it's basically you're just
you're cutting your calories too low and
you're cutting the nutrients too low
alright thanks for watching hey guys
thank you so much for watching please
click the subscribe button and I will
see you in the next video